okay gibt mit dem biest willkommen
bayern ein video und zwar habe ich mir
so gedacht hey komm mach doch mal wieder
so ein video wohl so über was aus deinem
leben erzählt und da ist mir so direkt
in den sinn gekommen hey die ist schon
so viel scheiße passiert erzählt doch
einfach mal ein bisschen macht über
peinliche situation oder peinliche dinge
die mir so bis jetzt in meinem leben
passiert sind wir sind sicherlich nicht
mehr allein gefallen haben ich hab mal
so 45 rausgesucht und ich glaube das ist
ganz witzig hoffe ich konnte mal in die
kommentare schreiben
das lustig findet oder nicht wenn wir da
oben lassen freut mich natürlich sehr
und ansonsten will ich gar nicht
angelaufen wir fangen direkt vor allem
mit punkt nummer zwei
sport1 hat er war jetzt super witzig das
ding ist bei punkt eins da kann ich mich
wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr dran
erinnern das wird mir nur meine eltern
erzählt und zwar reicht da glaube ich so
vier oder fünf und wir waren halt jedem
wie im urlaub oder so was möchte ich
wurde etwa irgendwo es war auf jeden
fall in deutschland ja irgendwie war ich
dann wenn eltern unterwegs und hab es
irgendwie geschafft abzuhauen ohne dass
sie es merken und sie haben irgendwie
erst zwei minuten später gemerkt und
dann war ich schon über alle berge
verschwunden und meine mutter wollte
mich dann natürlich suchen ich meine ist
ja klar dass mal seinen vier oder fünf
eventuell sogar noch 3 inso nicht
alleine irgendwo rum laufen lassen will
ja und da hatte ich mich wohl irgendwie
10 15 minuten besucht und war schon
total in party und irgendwann sagte dann
so hinten in der ferne so ein
kinderkarussell das tor gar nicht weiter
oder stand ganz viele leute drum und
dann dachte sie stores und davos und ist
das mal hingegangen und hat dann war ich
also da kam ich ins spiel
ja es war ein bisschen wie ich weiß
nicht welche mir daran erinnern könnte
das wäre eigentlich super und zwar ich
sag's dann wirklich auf dem karussell
drauf sind fünf oder zehn minuten und
ich hatte aber kein ticket deswegen ist
halt ich losgefahren und ich wollte
ihnen wir überhaupt nicht darunter also
mich hat keiner ich weiß nicht wieso
mich nicht einfach so ein typ genau und
runter gesetzt hat ich habe mich
irgendwie daran festgehalten dass ich
halt nicht runter muss jan stand aber
wirklich ziemlich viele leute drum und
die haben alle so auf mich okay hat das
kind keine
teils dass alleine ihr wolle oder was
gerade los also würde ich mich doch
wirklich daran erinnern können dann wäre
es wahrscheinlich heute ziemlich
peinlich für mich kann ich aber zu
möglich oder leider nicht weiß nicht wie
es ja auch eigentlich ganz lustig wenn
man sich noch daran erinnern könnte
und ich glaube dann habe ich mir auf dem
karussell auch noch in die hose gemacht
weil ich dann plötzlich angst hatte
irgendwie das war total kurbelt ich weiß
es nicht keiner kommen auch schon zu
punkt 2 und 2 ist das wirklich noch gar
nicht so lange her das war in berlin
letztens von 304 monat leister die video
days waren und ich war wirklich sehr
spät dran ich habe meinen zug gekriegt
um 8 oder so waren und 32 unternehmen
haupt bahn und bus überhaupt nicht wohl
irgendwas ist das ding war nur beim meet
and greet eine autogrammstunde trinken
will war irgendwie um 11.30 und ich habe
es irgendwie nicht so schnell auf die
reihe bekommen da hin zu kommen ich war
irgendwie um 11 15 in berlin an so einer
u bahn station hat man auch noch meine u
bahn erst verpasst das heißt ich war um
11.25 erst an der u bahn station wo es
zum video dagegen und musste mich dann
megawatt
ich hatte noch ein ganzes gepäck dabei
also bei den fetten rucksack und meinem
penny bord habe ich dann aufs penny
bottrop ich hatte mein penny borter erst
so zwei wochen also ich bin
aufgesprungen und habe dann richtig
durchgezogen und das irgendwie straße
dann wirklich scheiße das war da kann
man nicht so gut drauf fahren und ich
hab dann wirklich ab und zu schon die
kontrolle verloren und irgendwann so
hundert meter vom video day es war
wirklich hier war die schlange müsst ihr
euch vorstellen und ich kann deine
angedüst und ich musste ganz schnell
rein und dann bin ich ist mir ein fehler
passiert und zwar bin ich dann von penny
bord gerutscht
mein penny bord wo dann so ein bisschen
weiter in die richtung so ich bin
hinterher gelaufen und mein ganzes
gepäck alle leute konnten so her ist er
behindert was macht ihr nach dann bin
ich aus penig drauf gesprungen wenn dann
übels weggerutscht und habe mich einfach
sofort 30 leute oder so richtig aufs
more gelegt und da dachte ich mir dann
so auf hoffentlich guckt jetzt hier
keiner meine videos weil das war echt
für mich so ein scheiß staat so von den
han youtuber der will auch versuche
jetzt endlich bord fahren aber kannst ja
so ist das halt und ich würde sagen wir
machen auch direkt weiter mit punkt 3
und zwar ist das wirklich scheiße ich
kann es auch nicht mehr rückgängig
machen also meine alte nummer die hat
jetzt meine mutter und auf dieser nummer
die hat anruf kommt halt ne mail box wo
ich halt gesprochen habe weil ich halt
damals so mir eine mailbox gemacht habe
und ich weiß auch nicht was ich mir
dabei gedacht habe seine mailbox zu
machen weil ihr kriegs jetzt eben nicht
mehr aus ich weiß nicht das funktioniert
ein vielleicht also wir können jetzt
einfach mal meine mutter anrufe und mal
gucken ob sie dran geht und ich hoffe
sie gibt nicht dran weil dann hört ihr
die mailbox mal ich schreibe wie man sie
sollen nicht drangehen ich versteh gar
nicht was ich mir da ich meine jeder der
jetzt meine mutter anruf der hört mich
dann halt und denkt hey was hat dir
empfehlen so ist er irgendwie leicht
gestört komisch besoffen und ich schäme
mich selber diese mailbox sie geht
einfach nicht weg ich weiß nicht was man
sagt mir doch mal bitte was ich jetzt
machen soll
nein spaß also wenn ihr wisst wie das
geht dann schreibt zwar eine kommentare
vielleicht kriegt das ja dann irgendwie
nicht schaffe es einfach nicht so jetzt
kommen wir wirklich zu dem höhepunkt an
peinlichkeit meines erachtens nach
heutzutage und zwar ich habe ja schon
mit dreizehn oder vierzehn mal das ein
oder andere youtube video gedreht und
irgendwann kam ich auch mal auf die idee
zu singen ok viele von euch weitenjagd
so scheiße bin ich gar nicht im sinn ich
habe es ja irgendwann mal gezeigt link
dazu ist in der video beschreibung auf
jeden fall das habe ich halt auch mit so
einer richtig schlechten kamera den
gesang aufgenommen und ich habe dazu ein
video bekommen das zeige ich euch jetzt
einfach mal im kurzen ausschnitt es
kostet mich sehr viel überwindung
momentchen
das bin ich okay
zum beispiel von pro sob es gibt es echt
nicht irgendwas total gehörte und
kamelle 100 leicht auf facebook ja man
muss ja dieses video ist zum glück nicht
mehr online das war auch beim alten
kanal und ich glaube da hatte ich so das
video hatte sogar 1200 klicks und sogar
glaube ich irgendwie so 80 leicht das
war von mega krass für mich damals nicht
viel wie kann sowas eigentlich 80
leipzig weil ich singe scheiße das video
ist scheiße aber na ja so ist das ich
stehe dazu dass ich halt auch mal etwas
kleiner war und den größten scheiß
produziert ab so wie jeder andere
youtuber auch jeder war scheiße jeder
hat mal scheiße videos gemacht nicht
immer scheiße ist halt leider so und an
sonst würde ich sagen das war's mit
diesem video was wir auf jeden fall doch
noch obenauf entscheid gefallen hat wird
mich sehr freuen die monster und weil es
ein meldet hier oben links geht's weiter
mit meinem letzten video allerdings das
war damit mit christian und kumpel von
mir damals gegenseitig so einer frage
gestellt und an der ein oder anderen
stelle geben auf jeden fall war für mich
freuen ansonsten holt doch wieder eure
eltern an und wies